we play the game or we die
we were lucky to get out of those escape
rooms alive i need to know that the
criminals who killed the four people in
front of me
are held accountable we're hiding in
plain sight in the middle of manhattan
we need to stop them i'm in
i know this is a lot to ask but thank
you for coming with me
hey what the hell is going on
you're going to be kidding me hold on
welcome to mino's escape rooms no no
no it's happening again you guys have
played the game before
so what is this like a tournament of
champions
[Applause]
look we all know how this works we
solved the puzzles or we died
false advertising must be pulled this ad
yourself is missing an e
so maybe we pull the corresponding
handles with a missing letter
yes e [ __ ] henry
come on we don't have time
[Music]
this is way bigger than last time you
got to try something right
there's a special reason each of us
survived i
can't feel physical pain just imagine
the kinds of puzzles they came up with
for me
take a picture it'll last longer get
some clues
this looks just like the lighthouse on
the postcard
[Music]
it's over i'm done running we can beat
them at their own game
what makes you think they're going to
let you walk away free again
[Music]
we're going to get a kill i'm not
playing your game
not now not ever
we need it we made it
hey i don't understand we're still in
the game
you